ahora que ya que aparece su atención si
les doy la bienvenida y muchas gracias
ahora acá todavía si soy juez soy referí
y vengo a hablarles acerca de esa
perspectiva de la justicia a través
desde ese punto de vista sin embargo a
través de la de la charla vamos a ver
que eso va directamente con nuestra vida
solo quién se controla a sí mismo puede
controlar el partido se dirán pues qué
partido o qué deporte les va a hablar
del deporte más bonito que tenemos y de
más alto rendimiento nuestra vida propia
sin embargo esa vida propia a veces se
vuelve un deporte de alto rendimiento o
un deporte normal
de recreación esperemos que siempre sea
de alto rendimiento pero que nos haga
felices
debo hablar un poquito de algo cómico
escuché risas creo que es algo evidente
si mi nombre es jugo pero de hace mucho
tiempo no me dicen hugo me llaman up y
up creo que
ok parece que es evidente si viene por
el gran personaje diego gran personaje
apu el de los simpson sin embargo desde
mi perspectiva en ese entonces parecía
un poco injusto pero ahora es muy justo
que un compañero desde el otro lado de
la cancha gritara miren al negro con ese
casco que parece un turbante igualito a
pooh y desde entonces me quedaba en esa
época hace más de 15 20 años comencé en
mis pinitos como referí de uno de los
deportes que hoy por hoy me ha marcado
el rugby ya que es muy bien
ya que en mi concepto muy personal es un
deporte completo porque es de conjunto
con un balón pero también tiene contacto
en donde se debe llevar a la máxima
digamos esfuerzo la línea de contacto y
de presión física al oponente ahora bien
en mis pinitos como réferi nosotros los
réferis
tenemos que ser expertos en las leyes
reglamentos y maneras de jugar no
debemos ser volver expertos en los
premios de los castigos no solo para que
la gente se divierta pero es más
importante para que la gente al final de
los partidos al final de las contiendas
tenga un sentimiento de justicia diga
fue justo que el otro ganará fue justo
que yo ganara o que ganáramos en equipo
y fue muy justo que de pronto en algún
momento sacaran las tarjetas
ahorita digamos que les voy a hacer una
pregunta y sólo tiene que levantar la
mano espero que así como se rieron de mi
nombre de poder up participen ok tiene
de los que están acá presentes se han
leído el código de policía recientemente
excelente para ustedes luego a levantar
el dedo que es un premio para el resto
de nosotros una amonestación ok
claros en eso bien vamos a hacer una
tarea ya que ya los juzgue como referís
ahora ustedes se van a poner en esos
pies de referir o de juez vamos a tener
las siguientes tarjetas rojo para
castigo amarillo para menos acción y
verde para premio premium amonestación y
castigo entonces que algunos han pensado
así lo hacía el gran césar verdad
necesitan gran obviamente hubo muchas
personas que injustamente fueron
decapitadas gracias a
ok entonces por unos segundos vamos a
ver unas imágenes
algo que no lo pasa en nuestro querido
país este es un sistema de transporte en
un país con mucho potencial con unas
personas que se creyeron
con el control de meterse por donde no
debían ustedes
como jueces en esos pies con esos guayos
si quieren como réferi o como quien
quiera juzgar esa situación qué tipo de
tarjeta le daría recuerden premium
amonestación castigo vamos a ver
ojalá todos participemos porque a lo
mejor hemos visto eso perfecto muy bien
excelente
esta situación del lado derecho muchos
no saben que es el rugby es un acto sí
es un acto recuerden que las reglas en
los deportes de la mayores reportes es
para cuidar la integridad de los
presentes y también de los que ven los
partidos el lado derecho es el rugby es
un tacle alto si es una desfachatez es
algo que no se debe hacer sin embargo se
da pero no lo izquierdo también hay
tacle alto
exacto bien ustedes que le darían como
jueces tanto en la parte deportiva como
en la parte social eso es política creo
que veréis toleraría recuerden premio
amonestación o castigo
claro un castigo total sobre todo por el
cuello el cuello duele muy bien
ahora bien en el deporte como en la vida
también hay cosas más bonitas
tenemos las dos imágenes en la parte
deportiva aún cuando el de azul había
perdido el de rojo le tiende la mano lo
ayuda a levantarse en un acto de justa
igualdad y en la vida allí a partir de
ese enfermero quien le está dando una
sonrisa a ese pequeñito que a lo mejor
podría haber sido yo
como son mis gustos verdad para que
sepan mi raza obviamente no es de la
gran raza afro yo soy barcino mezcla
árabe indígena colombiano y español pero
bueno ojalá quisiera hacer ahora porque
sería mucho más puro
ahora se dieron cuenta si nos ponemos en
la exposición de jueces o de ser
juzgados todo cambia la justicia cuando
es individual se vuelve muy efímera se
vuelve del imaginativo y muchas veces
pues del orgullo yo les digo que la
justicia debe ser con sentido común sin
embargo el sentido común a veces no pasa
no parte de las sensaciones y pocas
veces del común y hay un gran dilema en
paradigma el cual viene de la mano con
lo que pasa en la sociedad
les contaba al principio que había
andado con los indígenas y que los
indígenas ya en forma de alguna manera
me decían apu en el deporte verdad yo en
una montaña caminando con un taita
escuché a po venga para acá ellos me
pueden estar sé cómo puede ser que en
bogotá y en colombia a través del
deporte me conozca como apu y un
indígena taita en medio de la montaña
sepa también que me dicen app yo le
pregunté en hatay está usted cómo sabe
que me dicen app yo no yo no sé qué le
dicen a poco sino que ustedes me pareció
no diré que es una app es el espíritu
que cuida la montaña o él sabedor de las
montañas que en últimas es el que
enseñan las reglas naturales que no hay
que ver solamente contaminar el agua que
lo que pasa abajo repercute arriba la
basura que hacemos abajo a través
el proceso de decantación y de
evaporación hace que haya arriba cuando
caiga el agua nos caiga la lluvia hacia
por si acaso para que dejemos de botar
basura entonces yo dije si en la vida
deportiva en mi vida personal y en la
vida que estoy tomando natural viene ese
nombre por qué no hacer algo con ese
nombre que es genérico volverlo un
poquito más adecuado entonces recordé
que la justicia cuando es individual no
es equitativa la justicia debe ser
grupal debe socializarse para que
nosotros tengamos ese pensamiento y esa
sensación de que a todos nos dan lo que
merecemos por lo tanto la igualdad no es
lo mismo que la equidad
tenemos que apuntar hacia la equidad y
como réferi lo logrado de pronto como
docente pero alguna persona o alguien
habrá podido liderar un país con ese
precepto y encontré las historias de
buda buda dejó a través de su vida diez
preceptos y es cualidades que debemos
tener los líderes o que debemos adoptar
cualquier persona o todos ojalá para
poder dirigir un pueblo
de manera justa ahí es donde entra este
personaje local grande
primero fue déspota acabó con muchas
vidas sin embargo encontró en las
escrituras y en los ideales de buda algo
muy bonito para elegir su nuevo país y
son esas diez características yo les
digo nosotros somos responsables de
votar somos responsables de dirigir o de
escoger nuestros dirigentes pero somos
conscientes de cómo lo estamos haciendo
estamos teniendo una concepción de
justicia adecuada o siempre lo estamos
haciendo por nuestro orgullo o por
nuestros niveles de creencias son cosas
del sentido común si las leemos dice
tiene que ser generoso ojalá que no
mienta ojalá que ponga el pueblo antes
de sí mismo hay cosas interesantes como
una vida simple austera eso me trae a la
cabeza un ejemplo del presidente
mexicano todo lo hemos visto y la gente
era feliz mientras estuve en el mandato
pasar todo en pro del pueblo no a la
obstrucción no a la oposición ser
sumamente paciente bueno son 10 ítems
que los podríamos adaptar nosotros
mismos yo creería que sí si los
adoptamos podríamos buscarlo en nuestros
dirigentes sería ideal ya las próximas
votaciones o elecciones tendríamos una
manera más adecuada de escoger nuestros
dirigentes y en últimas no quejarnos
porque nosotros estamos escogiendo bajo
un concepto mucho más real mucho más
social y mucho mucho más de sentido
común
acá es donde mi fe sería un sobrenombre
mi nombre de poder ojalá deje una
enseñanza de vida
yo quiero ser maestro soy docente soy
profesor pero quiere ser maestro y es en
el sentido de dejarle una enseñanza a
quien me escuche
ojalá eso nos sirva de aquí en adelante
yo lo estoy poniendo en práctica mi vida
y es el método pudo de justicia con
sentido común la de aprender que vamos a
aprender aprendamos la mayor cantidad de
leyes reglamentos códigos que nos rigen
desde las leyes de la mamá o del papá
hasta la constitución política yo sé que
no la dieron el colegio pero les aseguro
que si hacemos el ejercicio de lanzar la
mano hace varios días que no nos leíamos
no no no no la leemos a menos de que
estudiamos derecho de pensar como las
ahorita nos decían
pensemos antes de actuar pero sobre todo
pensar y pasar a participar participemos
de esas leyes hagamos la tarea de hacer
nos presentes cuando nos digan venga va
a haber una modificación de la
constitución pasemos a las urnas
nosotros no podemos dejar que unos pocos
nos sigan dirigiendo con las leyes que
muchas veces no se digan y muchas veces
nos desequilibra la justicia muchas
veces cuando se ve desde una perspectiva
no nos unen
en el lo más importante que lo que
tenemos que unir no sólo el conocimiento
de la unificación de criterios como
réferi lo más importante es todos los
del partido saben lo mismo saben que yo
les voy a pintar roja amarilla o por lo
menos le voy a dar un premio a lo mejor
no por eso es que hacemos la charla
previa en la vida diaria debemos unirnos
unirnos desde la familia hasta unirnos
como parte de nuestro gobierno y
magisterio bonito que sería de colombia
cuando todos hiciéramos parte de esa
diferencia o de esos cambios en las
constituciones en las reglas en el mismo
código de policía que muchos hemos leído
que decimos bueno por este lado no eso
por este lado si es y por último es
socializar y volvernos sostenibles en el
tiempo
si nosotros ya aprendimos y pensamos
antes de actuar y participamos
unificamos los criterios y nos volvimos
sociales imanes y qué bonito sería
nuestro país al saber que tenemos una
justicia con sentido común y mucho más
práctica para todos
por eso les digo que la vida es un
deporte de alto rendimiento pero sobre
todo es un deporte de exigencia y un
deporte que nos hace felices muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]